hey guys it is Friday which means I've
got five of this week's best stories and
gaming's get you all caught up on what's
been going on halo 5 guardians will be
locked at 60 frames per second but you
won't necessarily be getting 1080p
resolution for the duration of your game
a new blog post on xbox wire has
indicated that 343 industries will be
adopting what they're calling a new
progressive resolution system which is
basically a dynamic resolution the game
will run at 1080p when possible and
lower if resources need to be deployed
to maintain the frame rate in
high-intensity section currently this
dynamic resolution has been confirmed
for the games campaign mode and there's
no news yet on whether it will also be
used in multiplayer halo 5 is set to
launch on October 27 Witcher 3
developers that approach dread has
denied rumors that they're in talks with
EA about a potential takeover community
manager Martin mom won't replied to a
tweet inquiring about the acquisition
with what appears to be a pretty firm
denial of the rumor he said just above
gentamicin ave in ski it was new to him
I guess the informer has better insight
than the setup retread founder the
rumour kicked off from DSO gaming who
cited a statement from a set of product
employee claiming that EA reps were in
talks with top management about buying
the studio in June the developer said
that they had been regularly approached
with acquisition offers but didn't
intend to give up their independence
if cheap consoles are your jam you maybe
came to pick up an Xbox one for 250
bucks this weekend retailer gamestop has
revived its Xbox one trade-in offer
where you can get 100 bucks of credit
towards the purchase of Microsoft's
brand new console to qualify he'll need
to swap over your 120 gigabyte or
greater ps3 or alternatively your 250
gigabyte or greater xbox 360 shows you
want to take advantage the deal runs up
until sep tember 20 it turns out call of
duty aren't the only ones jumping on the
mini-fridge bundle bandwagon as you can
now get a han solo mini fridge with your
copy of star wars battlefront the bundle
which falls in a gray area between
awesome and insane will run you 130
bucks for that price you can get a
deluxe ps4 or xbox one copy of star wars
battlefront and a mini fridge with a
trapped han Solo embossed on the front
it holds up to six standard issue cans
includes a built-in carrying handle
removable shelf and warming function as
well as a 12 volt DC power cord in case
this is the thing you want in your car
for some reason the deluxe edition of
the game that it's bundled with has a
whole lot of bonus in-game content
ranging from weapons to M mode
finally the festa have come out to
defend the fact that they announced a
dlc / fallout 4 before the game was
released but there's de marketing exec
Pete Hines told a fan on Twitter I think
letting folks know our thoughts on it
and how it fits into our post launch
plans is a good approach the fan had
suggested it was irresponsible to
announce DLC before a game's release
that later replied they appreciated
Heinz's honesty in his response the DLC
will be delivered in expansion packs
which will start releasing next year and
you can access them via a thirty-dollar
dlc path let me know down in that
comment box if you think it's okay for
devs to announce the games dlc before
it's released or not and wide this week
on site I explain why Mario is a jerk on
the chest Dave cracks into fallout 1 in
our new fallout show and Lucy campers
pers 2016 and FIFA 16 on in two minutes
that is everything I happy this week as
always be sure to have yourself a lovely
weekend and I will catch you again on
Monday
you